[Music]
[Applause]
my view
[Music]
s
that's what I'll give you to decide your
faith
[Music]
Roberto tell me what did you do back
home
thank you
government work I'm retired
I understand pain death for you what was
that my Bandy because of these people
I'm beginning to understand real peace
Roberto this is my wife
oh and I'm starting to believe
they see you as one of us now this is
where I'm supposed to be thank you
what happens here happens in many times
the mafia
there's like cancer
[Applause]
no cue
[Music]
said you could come here
you should stay out of other people's
business
whatever it is you and your friends do
do it somewhere else you warning me I'm
preparing
is that a Timex no it's a book that's
the median nerve that I'm compressing
that's a level three this goes to level
four you will on yourself
[Applause]
seem like a man who understands violence
you can't take that from me
I can take anything I want
police found multiple dead bodies on
that farm in Sicily if you kill him
[Music]
do I look like a killer
foreign
[Music]